"Did you wash your hands?
With soap?"
If you want to know the secret purpose to
Amanda's key and other hidden clues about
future Saw movies then stick around to the
end of this video.
[Intro]
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Saw 3 brought back a lot of characters from
the first two movies.
We got to see Rigg, Kerry, Matthews and even
Adam Stanheight, who is played by the screenwriter,
Leigh Whannell.
After writing the first two movies, Whannell
would make Saw III his final installment before
moving on to Dead Silence and Insidious.
In one tweet, he hilariously claims that he'd
prefer Saw 3 as the end of the series.
"To be honest, I think they should have ended
it at 3.
I’ll admit it, I haven’t even seen Saw
5 or 6.
People ask me questions about “Detective
Hoffman” and I don’t know what the f***
they’re talking about."
Which is really funny, because Leigh created
the character of Hoffman, he shows up in Saw
3.
There are also a lot of clues in his story
that leave the third film up for a sequel.
I wonder what Leigh Whannell would say to
that?
“I’m a liar?"
Let's get into the Things You Missed.
Just like the first two movies, Saw 3 opens
with a light.
This time, it's the flashlight that Detective
Matthews would try to use to make his way
out of The Nerve Gas House.
The first proper trap of the movie is the
Classroom Trap, and we find out that this
one was never meant to be escapable, which
doesn't fit Jigsaw's pattern.
I guess Amanda didn't spend enough time in
Jigsaw's workshop and spent a little too much
time at Build-a-Bear workshop, because she
didn't properly learn the rules for making
a Jigsaw game.
Then, there's a curious line from Hoffman.
“All he had to do is release himself from
each of the chains and walk out the door before
it went off.”
“All he had to do?”
At the time that line was written it could
have just been a red herring, but something
later on in the film makes me think it is
an intentional clue about Saw 4.
It becomes clear to police that someone other
than Jigsaw is holding traps when they find
another inescapable one.
No Kerry, that's not what I meant when I said
stream sniping.
Last week when I covered Saw II, I mentioned
how some of the traps draw inspiration from
real life torture devices in history.
The Angel Trap seems to be a post industrial
revolution version of The Blood Eagle, a Viking
execution ritual that severed the victims’
ribs from their spines.
The same thing happens to Detective Kerry
after reaching into a beaker of acid to get
the key.
“All you have to do is reach in and take
it.”
Where have I heard that before?
“Takeeee itttt!”
Towards the end of the movie, we see a prototype
in John’s work area that is never seen used
on any victim in the series, but may have
also been inspired by a historical torture
mechanism, the Strappado, an invention of
the medeival Inquisition which left its victims
suspended by ropes for extended periods of
time to the point of body part dislocation
or death.
There was a third torture device inspired
by real life in this film, but I'll come back
to that later in the video.
After seeing the fate of Kerry, we’re introduced
to this movie’s main protagonist, a surgeon
named Dr. Lynn Denlon.
One of the big twists of this movie reveals
that she’s actually the wife of the man
making his way through the trials at Gideon
Meat Packing Plant, however, if we look back
there are plenty of clues.
When we see her at the hospital, she’s depressed,
and the only thing that ends up springing
her into action is when she sees that the
patient is a child.
Lynn was unable to do anything to save her
and Jeff’s child Dylan, who was struck down
by a drunk driver, so she probably couldn’t
bear to see another child slip away.
Then in her locker, there is a picture drawn
for her by her child, but what we don’t
know at the time is that it’s a keepsake
from her lost son Dylan.
The drawing of the pig matches what was Dylan’s
favorite toy, a plush pig that looks like
it could be from The Other Mother in Coraline.
“We need a yes if you want to stay here.”
“So sharp you won’t feel a th-- AUGH!!!”
Perhaps it should have been clear when Jeff
makes his way through his trials, and at every
step he is rewarded with a ripped piece of
this family photo.
The mom is deliberately kept from us until
the end, moments before we discover that Lynn
and Jeff are a married couple.
But the hints about their relationship weren’t
the only windows into the events that would
take place at the end of this movie.
Another twist that takes place is the kidnapping
of Jeff and Lynn’s daughter Corbett to be
used as motivation for a game for Jeff.
In the scene where Jeff is kidnapped by Jigsaw’s
apprentice, there are also very short flashes
of Corbett’s face, suggesting that she too
was taken in.
Jigsaw explains the rules of the game to Jeff.
“You will have to face a series of tests.
You will have to suffer to move forward through
each of them…
You will finally come face to face with the
man responsible for the loss of your child.
That will be your ultimate test.
Can you forgive him?”
We assume that he’s talking about Timothy,
the drunk driver responsible for Dylan’s
death, but when Jigsaw says ‘you will come
face to face with the man responsible for
the loss of your child,’ he’s really talking
about himself, the man responsible for Corbett’s
kidnapping.
Jeff’s final test is to try to forgive John
Kramer, who just put him through a whole day’s
worth of suffering.
Corbett is locked away in an unknown location
inside Gideon, a part of Jigsaw’s plan that
is perhaps hinted at by this sketch in the
operating room of an eye looking through a
keyhole.
Could the key that Amanda wears throughout
the movie, a key that we never learn the purpose
of, possibly be the key that unlocks Corbett’s
cell?
While following the pathways of Lynn and Jeff
have led us to some Things You Missed, the
biggest revelations will come when we take
a look at this game’s main test subject:
Amanda.
The true surprise of Saw 3 was the deception
of Amanda's status as a facilitator of the
game rather than a player.
The final scene reveals that Jigsaw was really
looking at her when he began the game, but
the rules can apply to both Lynn and Amanda.
"You are being tested.
Your will is being tested.
Your will to keep someone alive."
In a flashback, we see Amanda surviving the
reverse-bear trap from the first movie, after
which Jigsaw takes her in for her "rebirth".
There are a couple items in Amanda's room
within the Gideon Meat Packing Plant that
symbolize this, like this Botticelli painting
titled the Birth of Venus, and a Jigsaw puzzle
piece.
Amanda supposedly has the survival instinct
that Jigsaw victims lacked.
The failed subjects had their piece taken
from them, while Amanda got to keep hers.
Police figure out that the traps at the beginning
are unwinnable, and I mentioned back in my
Saw 1 episode that I think Adam's chain was
tampered with as well.
We see the bathroom game being set up in a
flashback in Saw 3, and Amanda tosses Adam's
key into the bath while John is not looking.
I think the key was supposed to be somewhere
where Adam had some chance to get it, giving
him the ability to roam around the bathroom by undoing his shackle.
In the montage at the end, Amanda's placement
of the key is accompanied by the narration:
"your games were unwinnable".
“Your games were unwinnable…”
There's also a point when John is speaking
to Lynn Denlon about his moral values and
sheds light on the reason we would eventually
find out, for Amanda being tested once again.
"I don't condone murder and I despise murderers."
Which is a fine stance to have, but you have
to apply it to yourself as well.
"I'm a murderer."
John should be holding himself accountable
for the deaths of the victims that he put
into his many traps, so let's take a closer
look at those.
If you ask me though, Jeff is going the wrong
way here.
I'd be headed towards those fresh and frozen
beef products.
When he arrives at the pig vat trap, the judge
just won't stop running his mouth, to the
point he started to sound like a talkative
video game NPC.
“Hello?
Help me, please!
Please help me!
I’m in here!
Please get me out of here.
Help me I-- Hello?
I know you’re there, please, please help
me!
I-I can hear you, please, answer me!
Help me!
Please!
Get me out of here, please, please.
Get me out of here!
PLEASE!
Don’t just stand there, help m--”
“Who was that Cryptushka?”
“Telemarketer.”
This trap is clever though because it's more
of an emotional suffering that takes place,
whereas the others focus on physical pain.
I think it's the only trap in the series so
far that's like that.
It's also pretty metal.
*metal music*
Drowning in the guts of a dead rotted animal?
"I hate to say it but yeah.”
“Yeah, not to be contradictory but it’s
very metal.”
The challenge is for Jeff to burn his late
son's possessions to obtain a key that will
free the judge from being drowned in pig guts.
The key is hidden in Dylan's favorite toy,
which was a pig.
As I mentioned before, pigs represent rebirth,
because the Year of the Pig in the Chinese
Zodiac is associated with the concept of being
reborn.
For Jigsaw, being reborn is the idea of leaving
your past life behind, and coming to appreciate
and cherish the joy being alive.
So that's why there are pigs all over this
movie.
I already mentioned Dylan's drawing inside
of Lynn's locker.
There's also these little porkers up here,
the pig masks worn by John's disciples, these
guys in the operation room and the pig hidden
at the top of Jeff's study.
Let's move on to the next trap.
What was the point of that?
This trap is another example of a trap that's
based off of a real world torture device from
history, but this one you're probably familiar
with.
The cross has long been a religious symbol
for some, but it gets its shape from the ancient
punishment known as Crucifixion.
Looking at The Rack makes me think of a more
technologically advanced crucifix.
I’ve talked a little bit about how John
tries to make his following very cult like,
but he doesn’t just draw influence from
one religion, there are also what I believe
are Buddhist figures with him by his deathbed,
and I’ve also heard the spirals that he’s
incorporated into much of his work have connections
to Buddhism as well.
I think that the imagery connected to the
cult of Jigsaw doesn’t stop with religion
though, he’s also taken ideas from other
cultures, like how we the Chinese concept
of Yin and Yang referenced right here, and
he also has illustrations of the solar system
because there are certain cultures who put
a lot of significance on the solar calendar.
I see the Jigsaw cult as kind of a melting
pot of different religions and cultures with
an emphasis on suffering to find enlightenment.
Jigsaw wears robes resembling those of a monk
in the scene where Amanda is reborn.
The room is lit by candle light, the music
that plays is titled Baptism in the Official
Score.
*piano music with chanting*
One more note on the Rack though.
Rather than having the feet together, like
you typically see on a crucifix, the feet
are apart, like the second position seen on
Leonardo Da Vinci’s famous drawing The Vitruvian
Man, which happens to be posted up all over
the operating room where that part of John’s
game takes place.
Right about now, you’re probably thinking
that “this Jigsaw guy is pretty sharp, the
kind of guy that’s so smart he wears his
watch on the inside of his wrist.”
Only problem is, you might want to turn on
your camera there, K Boomer?
Unlike Saw 2, there’s only one horror reference
I caught in this one, and keep in mind when
you see this Annabelle doll, this was years
before The Conjuring or Annabelle came out,
so this is a reference to the actual real
life creepy doll that the movies are based
on... if that.
I have done episodes on all the Annabelle
movies, but I’ve yet to cover the mainline
Conjuring trilogy.
Though that doesn’t sound like a bad idea
as a franchise to do after I cover Saw.
Now that may or may not be a hint at what’s
coming next on this channel, but one person
who definitely left hints at what would follow,
despite saying it should have ended after
Saw 3, was the screenwriter Leigh Whannell.
The first hint was early on in the movie when
John Kramer discusses his relationship with
Dr. Gordon.
“I was his patient and he was mine.”
Interesting choice of words.
But it also seems like the original plan for
Jeff was for him to survive and play another
game in Saw 4.
As I discussed, the ending alludes to a game
where he has to save his daughter.
“I am the person responsible for the loss
of your child.
I am the only person who knows where your
daughter is.”
Jigsaw also gives a cryptic warning, telling
Jeff that it would be dangerous to try to
move his dying wife.
"Though you may not see any threat, there
are threats all around you."
In Saw 3, we don’t really have any idea
what he means by this, but in Saw 4 we would
meet the threats that approach just beyond
that door.
Obviously the storyline did change in the
year that would follow, to where Jeff was
no longer the focus, but you’re not off
the hook just yet Leigh Whannell.
Remember that tweet?
I find it a little suspicious that Hoffman
was introduced in Saw 3, left as one of the
only survivors, and that this shot, which
has nothing to do with Saw 3, was added to
kickstart the beginning of Saw 4.
So if you want to hear about all the new Things
You Missed that Saw 4 had to offer, then remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
And wash your hands.